i'm all about pancakes about pancakes
come get them i'm hungry
hey what's up guys i'm chris red i'm
here with kenny thompson and we're
talking keenan season two two baby
what now
keenan
don't call me keenan i'm doing
interviewing so this is my interview pal
oh slap
what is season two like for you
we're having a good time around here as
you can see
i thought season one was a nice hey look
we got a solid like layered cast my baby
girl is lying to me actually bad at it i
used to lie all the time when i was a
kid i turned out great well you're not
great you sleep next to my water heater
and this season now we get to stretch
that out and go down like everybody's
little ladies you know they say
explaining the joke makes it less funny
but i beg the difference
especially the babies man babies you
ain't the big giant girl
baby you want to go play roblox
there's a wild woman pee in the backyard
is that why we got patchy grass
i like that we get to see keenan like
get get into it and some of your flaws
and how like yeah you get caught up in
this yeah i think that's important i
think it's almost better if i'm annoying
everybody
why i don't understand even though i'm
the only one talking is that what we're
doing hi i'm keenan thanks for waking up
with me and my million eye boogers got
one hard hitting question for the
audience though man i want to get real
serious okay
what's it like working with me dog
[Music]
oh yeah big smile now
yeah that's right
what is it like working with chris red
well it is um
it i'm sorry somebody call it
arizona
we've been on two shows so far that's
name candy mm-hmm what's our next show
cause it'll be like a competition show
we act like we're giving away money but
we really keep it i could see a buddy
cop but we're always looking for lunch
shout out to law and order
look out for uh
right here on nbc
for ages the black man has been seen as
many things but we have a sensitive side
i'm going to ask alicia to marry me
seriously dude i've had almond milk in
my fridge longer than you've been with
alicia we're gonna build we laugh
i couldn't find a coaster race house
you're out here looking like an
unfinished drawing
and we love
[Music]
tiff what the hell
grand cru special preview december 14th
on nbc
i'm losing my memory
sometimes i think about
what my very last memory will be before
the candle
goes
[Music]
it's out birthday and i would really
like to see the dance this is what you
want i love that for you
i don't know how much longer i have
before things get worse so i made sure
to remember every little detail big
three three three big three
three
[Music]
night
just breathe
come on now breathe with me
there you go
i would just wish that i could make time
stand still
time after sometimes
you picture it's the first time in 36
years you've said the words
he's my brother
you've said
and you say
go
slow
i'm not worried about forgetting about
the big stuff
it's the little things i'm not ready to
let go of yet if you're lost you can
look and you will find me
time after time
if you fall i will catch you i'll be
working the kids are old enough to start
making memories
important stuff they're going to
remember for the rest of their lives if
you fall i will catch
[Music]
until the day is over there's always a
chance you'll remember for something
else that's how we're gonna remember it
time after time
[Music]
my favorite movie is american gangster i
will be having a third talk with your
mom about what you're watching at home
i'm janine teagues i have been teaching
second grade here at abbott elementary
for a year now the staff here is
incredible there is a seven-year-old
custodian who voted for kanye teaching
social studies
that's who runs the world kids
i'm looking for miss coleman hello i'm
the sub oh i thought one of my
colleagues here hired a stripper for me
okay
the main problem in the school district
is yeah no money he tried this plus the
toilet the water shot back up in the air
no one told you about reversey toilet no
why is that even a thing
when the world sees just a day in the
life of being a teacher here you get
used to it in that smell in the wall oh
no you're never gonna get used to that
i believe that
if people don't awaken soon
something very bad will happen to us
i have to save everyone from their pain
i died and then i came back i can see
the world so clearly now i see through
the lies and the illusions that's a
level of narcissism that none of us can
relate to if that's not what crazy looks
like i don't know what it is she needs
like real help
dora's ideas could change the course of
human history
we can not only know love but be
loved you're starting the revolution oh
don't you feel it
[Music]
manju manja manja let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
we are trying to accomplish something
that has never been done before to sell
enlightenment
i'm with you me too let's do this
this is the revolution you sound crazy
i'm devoted um
things are going to get rocky
they might try to stop us
what you believe is not reality but they
can never take away our light
[Applause]
dory is not well we were in great danger
do you know what's coming total
annihilation
good luck to us all uh
today humanity's true nature is revealed
you did it again
we
are
evolving
[Music]
when
peter knox
murdered emily mother
he killed a woman that was like a mother
to my wife
i will make knox pay
for all of it
diana is pregnant twins apparently
the children of a vampire and a witch
the power they might possess is
unprecedented
how will you keep them safe
the book of life i'm trying to piece it
back together she has power but she
doesn't know how to use it
any threat to the existing order must be
extinguished you have no idea what i'm
capable of
do you think that this keeps your family
safe
you are wrong
he should know better than to threaten
me
if they take on one of us
they take us all on
if we lose any chance we creatures had
to live in peace will be gone
this is a world that we cannot
win
we should strike first are you ready for
this
let them come
matthew broke the covenant
you have no dominion here
we need more than a fight
we need a revolution
bring this rebellion to an end
i cannot
i'm ready
yes you are
[Music]
i can't believe she's gone i really did
think you'd be the first to go amy i'm
so sorry i promise i will be next
[Music]
if colleen's death has taught us
anything it's that we have to live our
best lives now i am gonna go home and
i'm gonna be a really good mom
who knew being a working mom would be so
hard everyone there are literally
shelves of books about it
[Music]
i waited too long to start dating after
my divorce put yourself out there
what that is that a nursing bra
i take care of everyone he just sees me
as another dried up old mom you don't
need to work out now that you're 40 it's
a downhill slide why fight it
i don't want you to die that's really
sweet donna's cousin tony died left
lorraine with the kids she looks so old
now oh
okay
do you think there's sex in heaven yeah
of course there's sex in heaven i mean
it's it's heaven colleen loved sex do
you remember at the church carnival when
she taught us how to work a churro with
our mouths
my life is a mess right now and i kind
of like it
you look like a tick taco oh
thank you amy
what is this uh a vibrator a vibrator
you mean my foot down there well it's an
upper up here sis
colleen was really proud of you guys
miss her she could see us now
she would die
i realize that's the wrong thing to say
now
this is not you
but i'm very proud
of each and every one of you for trying
to take this on because it's no future
in addiction
when i first met her i was just
immediately in love
[Music]
as soon as i saw her i was just
immediately afraid to lose her
when'd you relapse
[Music]
so
the 64 000 question is
what's in the suitcase
[Music]
there's a difference between what you
think you should want and what you
actually
want your favorite person
[Music]
i feel like i would look so sexy
pregnant noddy please do not get
pregnant
[Music]
wait why do you look like that like what
like a country music in a good way or a
bad way [ __ ] you better be joking
i came up with an amazing plan and what
would that be
so are you all ready to do some business
why can't i shake the feeling that
there's something you're not telling me
you're like a relationship kind of girl
right you guys can all judge me if you
want but i do not care i have never ever
been happier oh y'all let's get naked
right now
i love you
i've always been with you
from before you were born
until after you're gone
[Music]
how's your new year's going it's new
year's
new year
i swear my boyfriend doesn't tell me
anything
[Music]
you're back it's good to have you home
james
the best practice in glasgow they've
offered me a job but to work out if
there's something here worth staying for
oh someone helen
i'd like to have danced with you again
if your tours get
tickets do you try standing up to him
have you met my brother
no i'm always open to new ideas
i need to talk to you about glasgow you
belong here this is your home
all creatures great and small starts
january 9th only on pbs
[Music]
this is a family business
daddy's faculties are
waning the next logical leaders would be
amber and myself you're not the only
married people in this family me and bj
are also strongly betrothed not a real
family
no kids slam i like that one i don't got
time for kids cause i'm trying to keep
this fresh physique fine i'm not trying
to be all loose and stretched out like
amber's played out pastrami
this is a house that's jack bill y'all
remember this house
jesse and i are blessed to be teaming up
with lyle and lindy listens on a new
business venture
zion's landing christian timeshare
resort on the sunny beaches of florida
we got to align ourselves with the best
i mean only pure thoroughbreds that's
exactly how we see y'all too we do
powerful christian horses type folks
this is junior friend of mine from
memphis is this hot piece of tail that's
my daughter judy oh excuse me
and uh this one of her girlfriends well
i'm not a lesbian partner i'm her
husband b.j no dj he's big dick in you
[Music]
there's something else y'all should be
aware of a reporter is in our backyard
i'm doing a piece on your family you
think i haven't tussled with the press
before well a story i got isn't on you
don't dance around which one of my
family are you after who are you trying
to smear
we are in this reporter's crosshairs
let's go save our [ __ ] family
[Music]
you're gonna try to blackmail me tell
the story
let's not waste time
you don't know who you're messing with
i'm on the way up and you on the way
down
gunmen just tried to assassinate your
father
i'm trying don't you want to use your
[ __ ] car all we have to do is just
think for a second no we don't have to
think we have to drive my door's [ __ ]
opening back up now
god damn it
[Music]
hey everyone i'm ava duvernay and just
want to tell you a little bit about my
new friend naomi so naomi is uh pretty
popular uh she lives in the pacific
northwest in this little town called
puerto suego she has a really cool crew
of friends uh she's a snazzy dresser uh
she loves comic books in fact she really
loves superman uh comic books uh one day
something crazy happens in her town and
she finds out
why she loves comic books so much and
why she loves superman specifically and
it's something that blows her mind is
more seismic and cosmic than anyone
could ever imagine don't believe
everything you think that's what naomi's
about check it out
better hurry bell rings than 15. if you
let me get a car you wouldn't have to
worry about me being late
what's happening
[Music]
something happened to me i could hear it
annabelle hear what
everything
you were there that day do you know what
it was
it may have something to do with people
like us what are you talking about what
do you call an icon living
are you a superhero no no
i need you to listen to the vision
you're ready
i found the girl my powers are beginning
to manifest
new series tuesday january 11 free next
day on the cw app
[Applause]
since the show came out there was just
like so much craziness we don't see each
other as
celebrity not gonna worship nobody so
i'm not gonna make nobody feel like they
have to worship me
no matter how much i call myself the
queen
i'm here to cheer for monica
growing up we moved from house to house
i don't know where i'm sleeping tonight
but i know tomorrow at six o'clock i'm
going to cheerleading practice it's
definitely the hardest season i've ever
had
one of the show's breakout stars is
facing a 15-year sentence
i can't even like
process it right now
everyone just felt lost
cheerleading is the only thing that
could get my mind off of everything else
if navarro slips up this year
trinity valley is right there to snatch
the title from them
i'm fonte johnson and i'm head coach of
trinity valley
don't come to the valley just because
you want to be famous
come because you want to be the best
we're used to the david and goliath type
thing
but
the life is looking awfully big right
now
i don't need to win any more trophies
but i do want to be the best
my mindset was how i was in football i'm
not to destroy you
tvcc has the best tumbler angel rice is
the simone biles of cheerleading
but
it's not what you do it's how you do it
we go through this whole year grinding
and dying and getting hurt just to
compete
navarro and trinity valley
battling it out yet again
[Music]
have you ever heard of a guy named
peacemaker no
he is a trained killer
we've got trouble with that maniac
go what are you waiting for
that thing better not crap back there
yeah i'll strain an eagle dude that
without stealing its soul
hey dad
it's been a kind of rough go for me
daily dad you don't say somebody shot me
a building fell on me you let somebody
shoot you it's not gonna invite him to
come shoot me dad
pathetic
i thought you're in prison for life i
work for the government
post office do you think they'd let me
out of prison to deliver mail i don't
know it was the first government job i
could think of i killed people for them
okay
this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own we call our
targets butterflies they are a serious
threat to the safety of american
citizens
there's something weird going on you
think me and vigilante are too stupid to
notice hey everyone which one's me and
which one's easily okay you're half
right but you score 50 of the test at
school what do you get
school wasn't my bag it's for dorks
that guy's a clown but there's something
about him that's
sad
is your target in sight peacemaker could
take him out even the kids yes terminate
them immediately
take the socks
he told me to kill kids he didn't say
why
because right now the world needs the
son of a [ __ ]
you're the only one i got
thought you loved peace no matter how
many men women and children you needed
to kill to get it
i don't know i think i'm having feelings
about things
[Music]
dad maybe i'm a grower
not a shower what an individual you
don't like and then you learn to like
you're comparing yourself to a chode
not a bad way your dad is not a good man
still family my advice cut it out with
the introspection the mind is a den of
scorpions better left running from not
towards
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
two jerks and costumes and a couple of
rejects
it's like a real team out there
yo what the hell is that it's a grenada
tied to a russian tank shell why not
just the grenade gertie blows up like
two people how many people does this
blow up i don't know i invented it this
morning what
[Music]
eat peace [ __ ]
[Music]
every
[Music]
people think all those things i miss
doing with lisa i could just do them
anyway they're missing the point
i miss doing nothing with lisa
be strong everybody's struggling it's
not always their fault the last thing
you should do is drink alone
when she died everyone tried to help me
and they sort of saved me i feel that i
should help the people who helped me
[Music]
how do you do the hot ball you look sad
oh that's a waste i know a guy is really
into you what's wrong with him
could i just use your bathroom
honestly i i don't know where to start
[ __ ] me i thought you're having a piss
[ __ ] it now
i'm not gonna [ __ ] find me out try
any more zen
[Music]
hear that
shine your heart forward
[Music]
[ __ ] that how is that relaxing it's
disgusting
see you next tuesday you're not wrong
there you're [ __ ] snot curdling [ __ ]
[Music]
hey
it's a little bit early to be doing that
isn't it
it's 12 30.
[ __ ] really
nice underpants
oh
[Music]
i lost my sister six months ago you know
i keep trying to go through her stuff
and i get kind of stuck
what a [ __ ] a year huh
love you too dad
i'm so sorry about holly she was a few
years ahead of us right no i
i knew i recognized you
no you didn't
i didn't
i want to know i mean what are you doing
with your goddamn life i came home so i
could take care of holly because nobody
else wanted it right so that was one
year babe what should i eat
the mexican casserole is really good
there she is
i used to love watching you sing
you're so joyful you got the voice of an
angel what are you gonna do these little
invite to this thing i do
i think you'd really like it
[Music]
welcome to the fourth ever choir
practice y'all come on
this isn't like officially sanctioned
nice to
[Music]
one of my favorite singers in the entire
world is here with us tonight
come on up here
[Music]
i haven't done this for a long time
[Music]
god i can't believe i like know you know
you now
you're a big [ __ ] deal
[Music]
this is the story
of how i met your father
it was hard to live in the moment in
2022. there was always someplace else
you could be
someone else you could be with
i know this might sound crazy but i've
been on 87 tinder dates this year my
last date was the worst one yet i was on
another day before this and i just had
sex he told you that why would he tell
you that that's not even the worst part
to a night of new friends this is the
best place ever repeat after me today is
the first chapter of my next great love
story today is the first chapter of my
next great love story
you must be sophie it's a real pleasure
oh my god
screw being mature yes we can still make
bad choices for a few more years
this is the best night of my life when
you tell the story in the future just
promise me you will change that part
we live in confusing times until you are
completely insane i am very into it it's
really hard to meet someone and connect
and have it feel easy you gotta get back
out there sometimes yeah ever since
meredith dumped you i've been spending
50 bucks a week on kleenex because
you're crying or because you're going to
town on yourself crying bro
both
together we will take this city by storm
we are not afraid of you new york we're
the bravest people in this city
i'll drink to that
are you like me jeff goldblum maybe we
share an interest in
[Music]
monsters fireworks magic motorcycles
dogs
want to take some photos with him
[Laughter]
do anything i'm not doing anything
we like to go out into the forest and
look for things that may very well not
exist we build our own drone light shows
oh that's a jellyfish there some
magicians like to blur the lawn
what what what
amazing
my acting life caused me to seek
openness and interest in the unseen
there's always a moment of fear
oh wow
it's just the unknown i guess am i going
to be 100 safe you're going to be like
99.8 percent
here goes nothing i love to learn about
everything
this is terrible
really what makes us special as people
is that we have specific abilities to
tune in to others and cooperate and
collaborate boy i'm getting a lesson in
a lot of things i'm starting in first
grade in a lot of areas hi jeff wow eat
my dust we'll see who's eating stuff
sometimes life's most important moments
demand courage
the journey is it not the destination
enjoy the rise
gets 10 gold blooms out of a possible 10
gold worms that's my highest possible
rating
[Music]
the sonar detected it a minute ago
they don't look like rocks
[Music]
release the shark
look
oh my god
those are not shells boss
if you remember the beginning of titanic
i find nothing but wet paper
i think we just got a little bit luckier
yes
i'm here to claim a treasure in the name
of the kingdom
of spain
this is more than just a piece of gold
this is a dream
[Music]
samantha
i can see you
i miss being a drunk there's a lot less
accountability
[Music]
what brings you here today public
intoxication
destruction of personal property almost
blinding my co-worker
being awesome i hate to be a bus girl
hello smother did you just talk about me
the whole time yes mother it's all about
you
but yeah basically
i just got out of rehab i'm so glad
you're back we're gonna potty like when
tom was still with the patriots i can't
hey i wanted to tell you about this in
person my best friend's marrying my
ex-boyfriend oh no i want all the booze
and all the drugs all at the same time
you want to come in for a cup of tea
it's not blow but it's all i have i
don't want to be a bus
[Music]
didn't know there'd be so much stuff and
feelings or whatever that's the worst
part but like a long shot
[Music]
whoa
whoa good or well bad you're kind of
untouchable until you're a year and a
day sober who can i complain to
no one
what do i do just try to be a person
brush your teeth take a shower you make
your bed every day is the make your bed
thing metaphorical or should i really do
that
it feels bad and good at the same time
that's nice my friend is 30 days so much
you should be proud
don't judge me for having some wine at
night
it's hard to be a person
i hear you single drunk female series
premiered january 20th on freeform and
stream on hulu
you ready
i know that you can do it
let's check in on how our weekly goals
are going
as a part of moving into this apartment
we all agreed on a certain set of goals
yes i need to get and maintain a job
check and i need to make friends well
played jack thank you but i didn't play
well you played poorly you're very old
i'm sorry it's the asperger's he doesn't
mean it i mean it she tanked that hand
i want a boyfriend
it's normal to have a boyfriend look
he's so cute oh
i'd hit that
i'm injured we live right above you
i don't leave the building
why not
lots of reasons if you're lasting alone
or you're sinking like a stone carry on
do you want your dad to be supporting
you forever yes i have cancer jack i
need to know you're gonna be okay
we should have a date oh we can't have
sex on day one or date two but on day
three we can screw okay
what
jerry i'll carry on my roommate's
birthday starts in 92 minutes i have to
be there and it's going to be terrible
are you trying to invite me to a party
that's tragic
all that fear and anxiety that you're
feeling you just gotta push right
through it make that fear your [ __ ]
here's my [ __ ]
[Music]
i spent my entire life trying to hide in
the whole autism thing
i think you are such a beautiful person
that you shouldn't have to hide who you
are
that makes me want to throw up
[Music]
[Music]
a toast to motherhood
into new beginnings
[Music]
can i tell you something basically
sometimes i feel like i'm cursed i think
that everything's happening the way that
it's supposed to
this cult could come back for her at any
time none of you can protect me from
them
you wouldn't even know what to look for
are you feeding those squatters again
sean they're hungry kids dorothy
what if they're casing the place
i forbid you to go back to that park
it's so funny how controlling you can be
i think it'll be best for everyone if
you were able to make peace with leanne
why aren't you both so afraid of her
she's angry
i see
please don't hurt her
julian you're not telling me everything
what is going on
what the hell happens now
the end
i don't want to lose my son again
things are decaying
she's got to go
the house is filled with pests
she's like this world that gets under
your skin
this is my home
this is my family
and i will not let you take me away from
them
god didn't bring back jericho
and who did
[Music]
human beings make decisions they commit
acts
that makes things happen
creates a snowball effect
causes other people to make decisions
cycle continues
snowball keeps rolling
sometimes
people make decisions
[Applause]
you gotta act accordingly
or you can crawl in a hole
to die
new york is a collection of villages the
old have been in charge since before the
revolution
until the new people invaded
well i'm new i've only just arrived you
are my niece and you belong to old new
york
[Music]
george russell is a power in the land
before long you'll put money into his
pocket with every train ticket you buy i
think we should know the russell family
we do not move in the same circles mama
you are encourageable i take that as the
highest praise well how do you find your
aunts zeta is kind but not clever
and agnes is clever but not kind
mrs matton ryan and her sad sister were
spying on me today i don't know why you
bother with them
i don't bother with them i'm afraid new
york can be quite challenging at first
we haven't found it so have we joined
there is no challenge you are not equal
to my dear
we have invited marian to live with us
prayers and a penny
i cannot live with an antagonist's
confines
you must meet the right people
in the right way
money isn't everything agnes
i don't understand why they have taken
me in i have a job and a fresh start
that i need
i want to do something with my life for
a new yorker anything is possible
you are the future mrs russell and if
you were the future the name must be the
past
well things move faster nowadays
i hope you're not against miscop she'll
disrupt things maybe we need a bit of
disruption let the tournament begin
why don't we just go outside and roll in
the gutter it will save time
you know newport well miss russell the
mistress is not a player in the great
game
that woman is unsuitable as an
acquaintance
[Music]
i'll make them pay one day how can
anyone be so rich
you
bastard i may be a bastard mr thorburn
but you are a fool and of the two i
think i know which i prefer
[Music]
citizens of snowpiercer for the first
time since the world ended a brighter
future awaits beyond the train
there are places on the earth that are
warming
you will have a say in our destination
and your choice will determine our
future
hope is a slogan
an empty promise
there's only one way the way i do things
[Music]
my name is asha i am a survivor
you still don't get how it's possible to
survive eight years out there there's
still hope
it's time to go get our train back
wilfred hates surprises let's go give
him one
[Music]
i'm calling on you to settle this with
honor we'll finish this where we started
five
four
three
two
we keep everyone as alive as possible
minus an arm or two
[Music]
another day another near-death
experience right
[Music]
a portal to another dimension was open
end of the world type thing you are the
only ones who can close it wait
what
how are we about to save the world i'm
not good at being a teenager i'm looking
at anything
you have something
that no one else does me too
let's do this
be on the lookout and trust
no one
great i trust everyone
there's a reason you were chosen to do
this i guess we're monster hunters now
i get so much ass it's gonna be freaky
[Music]
foreign
is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
respect
rain
rain
come again
[Music]
[Music]
someone has been murdered
[Music]
what happened nothing happened what it's
illegal to make a false report anna
hey hello
how are you feeling crazy
great
i'm really cutting back
in the
pills i'm not
i just feel like i'm falling apart
like a house of cards
like a sand castle and the tide has come
in
like a rickety chair
or an old jalapeno
[Music]
hey hey
party people
big ups to hill mount high we started at
the upper middle
and now we're here
but for tonight me casa
i mean you know how the rest of that
goes whoa we gotta live forever
[Applause]
how did this all go so wrong
[Applause]
hop star actor and celebrity
humanitarian xavier was bound dead
tonight
his body discovered on the cliff during
an after party for his high school
reunion
this
is a murder
any one of you could be the murderer and
i want to hear your story the same thing
could happen but you see it in a
different way
i want to hear your mind moving
did you see her hair it looks like she
made out with a tornado
it's just jewish hair so much volume
my goal is to find out who killed xavier
now you all went to your high school
reunion
for what second chances at life
love
something else i would just love it if
you could just skip to the part where
the murder happened i'm telling you a
story here i'm building character arcs
dynamics
everybody here hated xavier he's the
worst i'm gonna have sex with your ex
dude
six years old daddy i love him
everyone seems to think you did it
everyone
it's all anyone's talking about
sorry you're you that's not fun
any one of us could snap what who whoa
you want to confess to a murderer
because we need to know who killed him
tonight bam
everybody seems to be hiding something
what is going on
we're done here yeah but you didn't even
know that was fake and you straight up
just chopped off his head
remember that
[Music]
this is our chance to show the world
that the roman family legacy will
continue beyond me
if you're not ready for this i guess i
just did not do my job right i live back
in the woods you see
my
we do what has to be done to protect the
family
i've been preparing for this moment my
entire life country folks cancer now
heavy is the head that wears the crown
baby
you